Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
The goal of this work is to have a robot that
automatically creates a 3D model of an indoor
space, including path planning and controlling
attention.
Now this immediately sounds like quite a challenging
task.
This robot uses an RGBD camera, so beyond
the colors, it also gets some depth information
that describes how far the viewed objects
are from the observer.
From this information, it tries to create
a 3D digital model of these interiors.
It not only does that, but it also constantly
replans its trajectory based on newly found
areas.
These paths have to be smooth and walkable
without bumping into objects, and of course,
adapt to the topology of the building.
You'll see in a moment why even this mundane
sounding smooth path part is really challenging
to accomplish.
Spoiler alert: it's about singularities.
With this proposed technique, the robot takes
a lap in the building and builds a rough representation
of it, kind of like a minimap in your favorite
computer games.
Previous techniques worked with potential
and gradient fields to guide the navigation.
The issue with these is that the green dots
that you see here represent singularities.
These are degenerate points that introduce
ambiguity to the path planning process and
reduce the efficiency of the navigation.
The red dots are sinks, which are even worse,
because these can trap the robot.
This new proposed tensor field representation
contains a lot fewer singularities, and its
favorable mathematical properties make it
sink-free.
This leads to much better path planning which
is crucial for maintaining high reconstruction
quality.
If you have a look at the paper, you'll see
several occurrences of the word "advection".
This is particularly cool because these robot
paths are planned in these gradient or tensor
fields represent the vortices and flow directions
similarly to how fluid flows are computed
in simulations.
Many of which you have seen in this series.
Beautiful, love it.
However, as advection can't guarantee that
we'll have a full coverage of the building,
this proposed technique borrows classic structures
from graph theory.
Graph theory is used to model the connections
between railway stations or to represent people
and their relationships in a social network.
And here, a method to construct a minimum
spanning tree was borrowed to help deciding
which direction to take at intersections for
optimal coverage with miminal effort.
Robots, fluids, graph theory, some of my favorite
topics of all time, so you probably know how
happy I was to see all these theories come
together to create something really practical.
This is an amazing paper, make sure to have
a look at it, it is available in the video
description.
The source code of this project is also available.
If you have enjoyed this episode, make sure
to subscribe to the series and click the bell
icon to never miss an episode.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!